idea i always had towards ginny that
david yates and i always played on was
this idea that she was this warrior
bonnie wright may not have had a lot of
speaking time in harry potter but she
was always there so naturally she's
incredibly involved we're going behind
the set of the franchise to see what she
was up to check it out you know we want
to sort of do as much justice to the
character as possible
number one we'd be claustrophobic if we
were stuck in a room full of teenagers
too bonnie loved filming the
dumbledore's army scenes in the room of
requirements despite the claustrophobia
she was experiencing she loved it but
near the end is when she started to find
there was too many people in the room
but she thinks that was part of the
reason she liked it was it was a room
filled with teenagers just being
annoying teenagers
number two this should be a tender
moment but it just feels super awkward
you just hold him because he needs to be
held now the director seems to love this
shot but we're not going to lie the
internet finds it just a little bit
awkward and it looks like bonnie wright
finds it awkward too but hey how are you
supposed to comfort somebody in this
situation we think it works just fine in
its cringiness thank you number three
bro zoned the only zone worse than the
friend zone bonnie wright's friends
actually knew about the shared kiss
between jenny and harry potter before
she ever did how'd they figure that out
well the books of course her friends had
a bit more free time than she did to get
caught up on them approaching the kiss
was way more daunting for her than
actually doing the scene though it was
actually easier than i realized as it
went on and daniel radcliffe found it
just a bit odd since he knew bonnie
since she was like nine and three
quarters and dan was 11. right yeah
that's so weird it may not sound like a
big age gap but in those formative years
it definitely is it's like being with a
sort of brother or sister but the whole
thing was very professional after
conversations with david yates and
rehearsing with daniel it wasn't really
awkward at all and a real off-screen
friendship really helped the romance
along she'd said it makes the on-screen
relationship make more sense this idea
that we've known each other and in a
sense grown up together off-screen as
well as on it was quite weird for bonnie
slowly growing into the idea of ginny
and harry being together because her
first exposure to it was harry was more
a close friend of the family just his
best friend's little sister in that in
that that was the relationship but the
relationship made a lot of sense to her
she believes ginny represents safeness
belonging and understanding and that's
why harry's drawn to her she's smart
funny attractive
attractive you know she's got nice skin
number four the best moment in the movie
change our mind turns out bonnie right
doesn't contain the same kind of crowd
silence and yell that the movie made it
seem because it definitely took a little
more than a yell to get the crowd
silenced
these quidditch players needed training
no muttering allowed instant pause
everyone
please be quiet please
shut it
also we love how take charge ginny is in
this moment she most definitely gets it
from her mom
number 5. growing up we wanted the
weasleys to be our parents too but then
we remember how molly weasley sent that
howler card to ron and we think twice
about it the family dynamic is bonnie
wright's favorite part of the franchise
understandable since it is the part
she's most involved in and julie walters
took the young bonnie right under her
wing from day one oh and ginny dear
congratulations on making gryffindor
always saying things with every film
like oh you were this tall and you were
this small which let's be real we've all
been there it isn't far off from what an
ant or a family friend would say huh and
that's not all to understand who's
playing her mother figure she went ahead
and watched a lot of the movies julie
walters was in which she ended up really
intimidated by her on-screen mom after
that ignorance is bliss in this
situation
number six divine intervention took
place here bonnie's fondest memory
filming franchise was actually her first
day being nine and three-quarter years
old stood at platform nine and three
quarters she remembers not having any
lines in the scene and at the last
minute being given just a little one to
say good luck
i felt like i didn't get too nervous
because it was just happening in that
moment if jenny realized she was talking
to harry potter then she might have
fainted
number seven the franchise might have
gone full circle but it feels like ginny
had less to do at the end than at the
beginning they definitely should have
let her say good luck again seriously
unlike her first scene she didn't get
any lines for her last one but she did
take on the role of the weasley mama
holding lily potter just as molly
weasley held her having the entire
series come full circle which she found
kind of surreal by the way the actor who
played her daughter is in her 20s now
moving on for bonnie and some of the
rest of the cast was a mixed bag of
emotions it meant more free time during
the summer but it also meant not seeing
each other all the time she considered
getting a tattoo with a few of her
fellow co-stars including tom felton but
the idea just fizzled away over time hey
maybe it's not too late reunion tattoo
anyone
number eight perhaps they both chugged a
bit of the love potion amortentia bonnie
wright and the young grindelwald jamie
campbell bower were getting cozy during
the filming of deathly hallows part one
in fact it's where they met within a
year of it they were engaged but by the
time 2012 came around they called off
their engagement saying that their
parting was amicable that's pretty fair
it happened so fast and they were so
young and of a different time period we
mean their movie personas did you know
jaime is the only one to have reprised
his role in the fantastic beasts series
number nine this scene doesn't look all
that safe to us if you look closely you
can spot that little flame beneath the
actor's feet as they hop over them and
run she tells all about her feelings
about ginny being fearless in this
moment just chasing after harry into the
reeds she just runs straight after him
so it shows a sense of sort of bravery
well ginny isn't the only fearless one
so is bonnie think about it what would
you say if somebody told you they needed
you to jump over flames we'd probably
quote the health and safety act number
10 stalkery much kidding it comes with
the territory of being a gryffindor
surrounded by other gryffindors there's
no moment for them to really connect
this just goes to emphasize our point
ginny's always around in the movies
always doing things always at the
gryffindor table eating with the rest of
her house or in this moment fighting to
save it they pass each other in the
battle and they sort of
have different looks towards each other
which tell a lot all they get is a few
glances that speak a thousand words
number eleven much like the weasleys
bonnie's family had her back bonnie's
older brother lewis who was reading the
harry potter books said that his sister
reminded him of ginny so she read the
first one fell in love and then begged
her mom sheila to get her an audition
she had never even considered acting
before this moment but given her family
owned to jewelers she was already
surrounded by artist types growing up
and it was a natural fit for her number
12. don't neglect the flirting seriously
those who didn't read the books
definitely thought hermione and harry
were going to end up together bonnie
would have loved to see more of the
relationship building between ginny and
harry in the movie
i can stay hidden up here too if you
like
she doesn't have any specific moments
from the book she'd like to have
included but she just wishes there was a
bit more nuance to the whole thing what
you mean this isn't nuance
bonnie wright was always there from the
time jenny got to hogwarts she was in so
many scenes and yet didn't say a word or
if she did speak spoke very little even
still she was a huge part of the
franchise ginny did marry our titular
hero after all are there any moments
from the books you wish were included in
the movie let us know in the comments
and thanks for watching
[Music]
you